des stages la psychanalyste françoise
dolto est morte hier à l'âge de 79 ans
avec autant de simplicité que de chaleur
elle avait su faire entrer la
psychanalyse dans notre vie quotidienne
et nous faire comprendre entre autres
que l'éducation des enfants ce n'était
ni le laisser aller ni les grands coups
diaka mais une oeuvre d' écoute de bon
sens et d'amour annie-claude elkaim avec
françoise dolto c'est l'une des plus
grandes figures de la psychanalyse en
france qui disparaît aujourd'hui l'une
des plus grandes l'une des plus
populaires aussi par ses ouvrages par
ces émissions et par sa pratique
quotidienne de psychanalyste pour
enfants dont elle était une des
pionnières
elle avait toute sa vie durant avec son
parler clair et son souci du faire
savoir le vrai pour la cause des enfants
et les parents voudraient que leurs
enfants soient soit la réussite totale
qu'il ne soit jamais malheureux or un
enfant qui se serait jamais malheureux
ce n'est pas un être humain un être
humain ne peut pas ne pas être
malheureux mais s'il peut exprimer à
quelqu'un qui ne va pas tomber
malheureux parce qu'il va le lui
exprimer mais qui va l'aider à dépasser
ce malheur et en tirer une expérience
alors il fait office de parent qui aide
son enfant à assumer les épreuves les
épreuves d'un être humain sur terre qui
n'arrivera jamais à se faire comprendre
par un autre jamais jamais à travers
nombre de ses ouvrages c'est cette vie
quotidienne que françoise dolto a
analysé y compris dans les derniers
d'entre elles venaient à peine de les
terminer
l'un d'eux était consacrée à sa propre
enfant
dans la vie de tous les jours quelle
genre de personnalités tel travail
extraordinaire d'une enfin d'une
d'optimisme absolument fantastique d'une
vitalité inwi est toujours prête à
commandite toujours prête à encourager
elle avait d'ailleurs ça en commun avec
lacan encourager les autres à faire des
choses qu'elle pénétrait dans un studio
de radio
je me souviens des années 80 a été
beaucoup plus dynamique que nous elle
nous pousse et en toute chose